diese youtube sie ist witzig aber die
macht auf youtube werbung für eine
pornoseite services kids und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video und
heute leute haben wir wieder richtig
heftiges heftiges scharfes zeug am start
die hat mir mal wieder videos
vorgeschlagen die ich mir als youtube
kunis als youtube ja keine ahnung welche
funktion nicht einmal anschauen soll und
ich muss sagen ein großer der videos die
meere geschickt hat war eigentlich
relativ normal das war so appelt hier
die nicht die pille ist aber eine sache
stach heraus
dieses video was herausstach stand von
katja gasser wird ja die macht immer
noch videos und das video was wir uns
heute anschauen ist
ich habe auch diesen link drauf geklickt
ja da war dieser twitter post gefragt
habe antwort von diesem zuschauer und
ich klick auf diesen link drauf und ich
denke mich trifft der schlag dieses
video ist so wächst mal richtig was zur
hölle alter heute wird's ab geht er
heute wird richtig sexy wo ich glaub ich
ziehe mich schon möchte von allen guten
geistern verlassen
leute ihr habt jetzt gerade schon titel
und fand bei von diesem video gesehen
ich weiß es noch nicht ich muss das
machen und ich werde versuchen das video
so gut wie möglich zu entschärfen
wahrscheinlich wird es trotzdem ein
erstes stück das video gar nichts machen
das ist dass leute schnell über vorab
stellt euch mal vor irgendein anderer
youtuber als katja beginnt so seine
videos ihr würdet den doch auslachen
machen hey leute ich bin's katja das
muss überzeugt dass lässiger com okay
hey leute ich bin's katja und in meinem
bett passieren fast nur heißt sachen
manchmal auch kalt sache ach so ja das
video heißt ja auch so alte das ist
etwas ganz anderes und 80 sowie von
katja anzuschauen ist was ganz ganz
anderes als alle anderen video übrigens
da wollen wir nicht überspringen am
anfang hatten wir hier eine
produktplatzierung da oben links sieht
das geschulte auge unterstützt sich
produktion desto so real
schaut euch einfach dieses standbild an
das kann doch nicht sein ich will jetzt
gar nicht den oberlehrer spielen das
sagt dass das böse aber schaut euch
einfach dieses standbild an das ist
nicht porno ab das ist youtube
[Musik]
ja das findet man auf tollen seiten im
internet wo du eigentlich auch sein soll
dass katja liebenswürdig übel ich muss
sagen die videos sind schon irgendwo
witzig weil diese ganze sache ist
einfach absurd ja das ist youtube und
hat auf dieser plattform achtjährige
kinder die sich irgendwelche playmobil
mittelalter ritter videos anschauen
wollen und da kommen die auf so was
das passiert im jahre 2017 in diesem
land in dem wir leben
dass das müsst ihr euch mal vor was soll
ich nicht doch doppel aber ich hatte
dieses video gesehen dachte ok kommen
wir schon so ist man aber als habe ich
hier so ein video mit den fünf besten
pics tipps alter das wollte ich das war
eigentlich nicht im sinne des erfinders
falls ihr euch denkt sebastian etwas
gemacht diese scheiße in deinen videos
sorry ich habe einfach nur das erste
standbild gesehen dachte mir kommen aber
jetzt leute nicht zu übertreffen jetzt
stecken wir drin von kopf bis fuß in
katjas sumpf ja indem sie uns heute die
fünf besten tipps zeigt um sich für
richtig einen von der palme zu werden
leute wie uns bleibt nichts anderes
übrig als jetzt wirklich inhaltlich
darauf einzugehen okay wer macht sowas
wer klemmt seine hand in den klodeckel 1
das ist ein fucking klodeckel dass das
uni dänische aller zeiten
[Musik]
leute was war das geht doch nicht vorher
das video heißt nicht fünf verrückte
abends sondern das video heißt so kann
man richtig
katja willst du mich hoch oben hebt das
ist doch nicht richtig wird sie leute
vermittelt den leuten bild dass das die
richtige art und weise der
selbstbefriedigung ist ja fucking haltet
euch fest hackfleisch ja da ist schon
das hoch drin in dem wort hackfleisch in
eine thermoskanne zu füllen den kennen
wir schon
das heißt
münchen hinten sorgen ja das habe ich
nicht gewusst was ist mit der sorge ich
komme nicht auf mein leben klar was
mache ich was mache ich wenn mir alter
liga
[Musik]
tipp ab checken abchecken ob jemand zu
hause ist katja menschen haben visuelle
organe und auditive organe menschen am
augen und ohren menschen können ihre
umgebung wahrnehmen ja da muss man nicht
erst abdecken so hatte motto okay ich
habe heute meine augen jetzt drei
stunden ausgeschaltet schaut sie kurz an
um zu checken ob sich jemand im haus
befindet das sieht man das ist doch kein
teppich wetter wird euch
katja hat sich diese liste fünf minuten
bevor sie das video gemacht hat
aufgeschrieben mehr bedenkzeit kann da
nicht rein fließen maximal 5
ok womit man leute in welcher situation
in der man sich selbst befriedigt sollte
man kopfhörer leise machen weil achtung
jemand die geräusche aus den kopfhörer
anhören könnte ja ok hat ja die einzige
situation die ich jetzt gerade denken
kann in der lautstärke aus den
kopfhörern eventuell die person um mich
herum stören könnte ist in der fucking
bahn ja im zug im ic von köln nach
münchen okay da könnte es leute stören
aber was macht man im ic von köln nach
münchen nicht genau sich einen von der
palme wählen verdammte axt in welcher
situation muss man die lautstärke runter
drehen bei leute sonst einen höheren
würden
ich mein man sitzt da mehr oder weniger
entblößt und wir sind nicht ein von der
franken fall bestellen ich hab so viel
spaß weil dieses video stellt euch das
vorsitzt sich immer dem zug stellt katja
sitz im zug zwar erster klasse weil wir
richtig läuft sie hat die lautstärke
leise ja es kann niemand stört aber
schön nackt geht richtig ab so dicht am
hobeln zeigt aber die lautstärke ist
leise also man kann sie dabei erwischen
[Musik]
okay wir dass skype mit oma während man
sich selbst bewegt muss ich dazu doch
irgendwas sagen
wie war das mit dem ziel hatte sie am
anfang nicht gemeint dass sie fünf dinge
vorstellen
also hier wird nicht genau mitgezählt
aber ich glaube es waren schon sieben
bisher ja und jetzt kommt nummer eins
[Musik]
okay was sie gesagt fundorado okay wir
schauen wir was fundorado ist fundorado
ist the fucking pornoseite wie zur hölle
geht's was es immer noch youtube das
dürfen wir nicht vergessen leute wir
sind es mittlerweile gewöhnt aber es ist
immer noch youtube gibt es da draußen
nicht eine einzige person bei youtube
das check diese youtuber in ja sie ist
witzig aber die macht auf youtube
werbung für eine pornoseite darüber
hinaus ist die ultra leicht bekleideten
dass der hauptsitz in ihrer videos aber
wie krass ist das sind wann kann man auf
youtube werbung für porno seite macht
und ich vielleicht nicht den oberlehrer
spielen aber irgendwann ist das maß halt
auch voll also wie kann machen was sie
will aber werbung für pornoseiten machen
wo man mal schnell was dafür bezahlen
muss wisst ihr wie viel achtjährige
jungs jetzt so kreditkarte ihre eltern
rennen
dann darf man dieses video und ich würde
sagen wenig 100.000 dollar
[Musik]
heute machen wir deckel drauf was machen
wir einfach den deckel drauf ok darum
nach oben sidekick touristen zeit bis
zum nächsten mal allein macht's gut und